Молдова далеко від столичної суєти.
Від Придністров'я до Гагаузії
Про страхи:
- Це - російська армія.
Коли НАТО чуємо - страшно, тому що боїмося, що увійдуть...
Про надії:
- Ми румуни і хочемо померти румунами.
Одні - мріють про Європу, інші - ностальгують за СРСР
і симпатизують Росії.
- Я в душі взагалі проросійський
МОЛДОВА. Між Сходом і Заходом.
Cело за півгодини їзди від Кишинева.
Це місце називається Нові Русешти,
А перша вулиця, на яку ми звідси потрапляємо,
в народі називається "Нова Рублівка".
Паралель з російською Рублівкою - елітним передмістям Москви -
виникла не випадково. Більшість будинків
були побудовані трудовими мігрантами на гроші, зароблені в Росії.
Але останнім часом жителі найбіднішої країни Європи
дедалі частіше їдуть на заробІтки на Захід.
Крім "Рублівки", у колись непримітних Русештах
стали з'являтися нові розкішні оази -
своя "Франція" і навіть "Ірландія". Так назвали місцеві мешканці ці будинки -
за назвами країн, куди вирушили на заробітки їхні господарі,
розповідає місцевий "примар" - глава адміністрації Павел Кодряну.
Не в останню чергу цьомУ сприяло масове отримання громадянства Румунії,
а отже і Євросоюзу. У Кодряну - як і в понад
півмільйона жителів Молдови - румунський паспорт.
Я перетинаю кордон вже як громадянин Румунії і Євросоюзу.
Я йду на вибори, обираю, кого хочу,
щоб у Румунії там було керівництво...
Майбутнє свого села і країни загалом Павло Кодряну
пов'язує насамперед з Євросоюзом.
Він вважає, що там у людей, особливо молоді,
більше шансів чогось досягти.
Європу вибрали для себе і його троє дітей.
Здобули освіту, облаштувалися, створили сім'ї.
Дочка - в Голландії, сини - в Румунії.
З нашого села дуже багато людей їдуть у той бік - в Європу,
виросли, отримали освіту.
нас є доктори наук, бізнесмени,
у нас є люди, які шановані там.
А в Росії що? Тільки на будівництві і на базарі.
Наші діти, молоде покоління - в Росії вони не виростуть.
А це - Варниця.
Прямо вулицями цього міста проходить
лінія розмежування з невизнаним Придністров'ям.
Поряд з бідністю тут досі видно сліди
воєнного конфлікту дев'яностих років.
Варниця контролюється Кишиневом, при цьому  розташована
на території, претензії на яку висуває Тирасполь.
У саду Симіона Бринзи чверть століття тому були окопи.
Зараз тут грядки і квіти.
Але відлуння військового конфлікту не дає спокою.
Небезпека з 92-го року, коли війна була тут,
як би, ось вона - 14-а армія.
- Це яка армія?
- Чотирнадцята? Це - російська армія.
- Тобто небезпека від Росії?
- Я не знаю, наскільки небезпека від Росії.
Небезпеки більше від того, скільки тисяч тонн вибухових пристроїв,
снарядів і так далі, які знаходяться в Ковбасках  -
є місцевість Ковбаски тут -
які зберігаються на складах.
Ось це небезпечно, дуже небезпечно.
Це належить 14-ій армії Росії.
Якщо щось трапиться, рвонуть ці склАди...
Не знаю, що залишиться від Придністров'я і Молдови, і Варниці...
Це дуже небезпечно.
Скільки ж років говорять про її вивизення,
про зняття з нас цієї небезпеки?
Але поки нічого не робиться. Це справа політиків.
Попри підтримку міжнародних посередників
Кишиневу так і не вдалося домогтися виведення російських вояків з Придністров'я.
Симіон не втрачає надії, що рано чи пізно це все ж станеться.
Щодня він облаштовує свій сад.
Для онуків, каже чоловік.
Він сподівається, що їхнє майбутнє буде європейським і демократичним.
Симіон називає себе патріотом своєї землі, яку вважає румунською.
Він "уніоніст" - прибічник об'єднАння з Румунією.
Уніоністи активно голосують на румунських і європейських виборах.
А деякі навіть балотуются від румунських партій.
Втім, велика політика жителям Варниці здається дуже далекою.
Тут відчувається втома від блокпостів.
Магазин Івана Пашкана знаходиться прямо біля одного з них.
Раз на тиждень "залізна завіса" відкривається, розповідає підприємець.
- У четвер у нас пропускають вліво і вправо.
- Що значить "у четвер пропускають вліво і вправо"?
- Ну, в четвер до Варниці приїжджають італійські автобуси з подарунками.
Починають шукати, хто що привіз.
Люди, які працюють в Італії, посилають своїм родичам передачі.
Це допомагає нам жити, виживати.
Під боком контрольоване Росією Придністров'я.
І тут же впадає у вічі реклама посередників,
які обіцяють допомогу в отриманні румунського громадянства.
Життя на лінії розмежування - це життя одночасно в двох реаліях.
У цій зоні ми можемо дивитися два канали -
один молдовський, а інший придністровський, проросійський.
І робимо аналіз, де правда і де брехня.
Тут у Варниці люди отримують не тільки російські новини,
загалом заборонені в Молдові, а й дешевий російський газ, розповідає Іван.
Родючий ґрунт для ностальгії про спільне з Росією минуле.
Дух тих двохсот років, які ми жили разом.
Цей дух не можна знищити за один день.
Все одно десь наша гостинність,
десь наше всередині духовне:
піонерія, ми всі були комсомольцями, пройшли через це.
Я в душі взагалі проросійський.
Але з огляду на те, що між нами Україна,
і якщо не буде інвестицій російських, як були після 40-го року,
то ми тільки в Європу маємо дивитися.
Передача "Моя Європа".
Кишинівські журналісти говорять про реформи, які підтримує Євросоюз.
У маленькій Молдові російські телеканали, що пропонують
яскраві розважальні програми, залишаються найпопулярнішими.
Але інформаційні телепрограми з Росії в країні заборонені.
Перед молодими журналістами, як Маріана Рац,
це відкриває додаткові можливості.
По-перше, у нас культура читати, дивитися російські новини.
Це ще з Радянського Союзу,
навіть румуномовні мешканці країни теж читають російською
і дивляться російські телеканали.
ТВ-8 - це не телеканал одного мислення, однієї ідеї.
Є місце для різних думок, головне,
щоб не віддавалася перевага одній думці з усіх, які існують.
Тим часом Гагаузія на півдні країни живе своїм життям.
Тут розмовляють переважно гагаузькою та російською.
Росія або Туреччина в цих місцях здаються ближчими, ніж сусідня Румунія.
Олена Гаргалик пишається гагаузькою культурою й унікальною кухнею.
Жінка веде велике господарство,
без чоловіка виховала чотирьох дітей.
Вона зізнається, що в політиці не тямить.
Але коли слухає новини, їй стає тривожно за майбутнє своїх дітей.
Коли НАТО чуємо - страшно, тому що боїмося, що увійдуть…
щоб не увійшли, чи не накоїли чогось.
Здається, що можуть все забрати, що захочуть.
А з Росією якось спокійніше.
Я з 16 років з Росією - ось як працювала при Союзі, встигла.
І мені здається, легше з ними.
Про ті часи кого не спитай - всі кажуть дуже гарні часи були.
Двоє дітей Олени вже живуть у Росії,
жінка мріє переїхати ближче до них.
Є така програма з переселення.
Подаєш документи, там розглядають,
і їдеш потім спокійно в Росію.
Поки одних молдаван Росія вабить програмою переселення,
сотні молдавських сіл нещодавно символічно
заявили про приєднання до Румунії.
Ось і в Нових Русештах мер і депутати сільради
підписали символічну декларацію про приєднання -
на честь сторіччя входження Бессарабії в Румунську державу.
Тому що ми - румуни, ми звідти прийшли.
Нас історія кидала то до румунів, то до Росії,
то до губернії і так далі...
Так, є такі, хто сказали, що не треба було цього робити,
чому не запитали всіх людей...
Але це було символічне від консиліуму 15-и консельєрів-депутатів.
навіть не думав, що всі підпишуть.
Молдова - дуже маленька, але строката країна.
Між Сходом і Заходом.
Минулим і майбутнім.